[Music]
hello and welcome to this video yeah
this is the video for chapter 9 of our
repertoire fight before like Caruana
chapter 9 and deals with what I call the
modern main line of the petrov the
modern main line goes like this white
takes on e5 and in this position plays
the move Knight c3 yeah this has become
probably the most popular tribe under at
the professional level and it also is
played regularly or on lower levels
nowadays what is the idea of Knight c3
yeah the main idea is that Y develops
quickly and after the most natural and
probably best move Knight takes c3
intends to take with the D pawn this is
some the pawn structure that white is
going for and it needs to be mentioned
that this is actually a very decent pawn
structure for white on the Queen side if
you have castle down so white will
almost all of the time a castle or Queen
side and argue that a king on c1 or b1
will be very safe again yeah shielded by
those four pawns that is definitely a
valid argument white sir next move will
be most of the time and put the bishop I
would probably to e3 Queen d2 castling
long that will be the general way that
yeah that white develops in this in this
line there are some other alternatives
along the way but this is the usual
development scheme first of all I'd like
to quickly tell you that in this
position black does not need to take
it's not absolutely forced move you can
also play the move Knight to f6 and just
in case that you have a look what I play
look in the database I have played this
move quite a bit
get played in one classic guitar control
game it also in some blitz games on my
on my youtube channel the reason why I
played this move is that when I yeah
adopted the petrov in late 2017 i did
this in a very quick and dirty way and
ik studying for two or three hours and
trying to pick sidelines that are
playable but don't require much work and
this is how I came up with nine of six
because when you only have half an hour
to prepare a surprise opening it's good
to splay surprising lines so this is
what I don't think is the best movie
just what I felt was good for me at the
time taking on c3 it's certainly the
more principled and yeah better move I
guess and also the one that Caruana has
played exclusively so why do we kept
just with the D pawn as mentioned if he
does take with the b-pawn it would be a
bit surprising but it can happen here we
are not overly concerned we have a very
young logical way of developing here we
can cast off short with B take c3 White
is never going Queen side so both sides
will be on the Kings side here with a
king and here I just wanted to point out
that c5 is a good idea in such a pawn
structure we attack the wide center and
yeah generally yeah good virtue of the
petrov is that all our pieces are active
here we can easily develop with normal
moves it's very harmless actually B
takes c3 so Y takes with the D pawn
after which Bishop e7 is the absolute
main move and what I recommend yeah the
reason why to go Bishop e7 first is just
like we know that the bishop has to go
to e7 there is very very little
likelihood that a different square would
make sense while we don't know quite yet
if we want to have the knight maybe here
or here or whatever so it's a matter of
of logic that you should do this first
in a way I have to mention though that
we will play Knights
takes all the time so it wouldn't make
much of a difference for our particular
lines that we go from here
White's by far main move is the move
Bishop to e3 yeah and it's it makes a
lot of sense yeah but wants to play this
next and the bishop has a natural square
only three there is a very related
variation the move Bishop to f4 and
those two moves Bishop f1 Bishop b3 we
will tackle with exactly the same setup
and in most cases there won't be any
substantial difference in terms of what
black play looks like there will just be
two three lines where play is a little
bit different with the bishop on f4
instead of III so after looking at some
some other very briefly possibilities
besides the two bishop moves we will
look at them they are closely connected
to one another because of the
similarities first I want to quickly
point out that if white makes it a
priority to Castle kingside
there is really nothing to fear white
may play this we go knight c6 and now
white may still transpose two lines with
Bishop e3 or Bishop f4 that we will look
at them in a minute if he castles King
side there will be absolutely no problem
for us we can also cancel king side and
the position like that really oops
yeah the software sometimes has to scale
it sheds on it like once every video
here black has no problems at all yeah
we can develop easily and White has very
little that he can try in such a
position and it's just he has really no
argument why he would be in any way
favored him the same kind of position
can also come on the board with Bishop
to c4
yeah Bishop to c4 instead of Bishop d3
those those two moves are basically the
same thing
we can play like this no matter if the
bishop runs on c4 oops I'm sorry if the
bishop is on c4 on d3
the short castling setup here is just
extremely healthy for black so we have
to look at the bishop moves Bishop f4
and Bishop to e3 going back to this
position Bishop f4 and Bishop e3 I am
starting with Bishop f4 that is just
currently I'm the less important move
there should be 3 is played far more
often and once we have looked at both I
think you will also understand why the
move to e3 is the more popular at the
moment so our setup is to play with
knight c6 in general I do recommend to
develop with 96 and Bishop e6 and to not
Castle kingside quickly this is possible
you can Castle kingside
here on move 7 or after Bishop b3 also
on more salmon you can Castle kingside
but I want to be more flexible them the
kings are cancelling in general needs to
yeah sharp a play we're wide I feel has
the easier game because his King on c1
or later b1 will be very safe and legs
counter play is not that pronounced we
will have lines where we do Castle
kingside
but that will be in cases where I feel
there are pieces traded already or where
why it setup is not optimal to play
against the King on g8 so how does white
continue most most of the time just
Queen d2 to prepare the castling move to
the Queen side what white may also play
like this this setup with Bishop d3 and
Queen e2 we will also examine a little
bit later with the bishop on e3 there
always two versions of that once bishop
on air for once bishop on e3 and the
main point of White's
plane here is that
in this situation and it is the same
thing almost with the Bishop 23 that
castling queenside is not a great idea
the problem is if we go Queen side I
just want to show you the point then the
move Bishop b5 is extremely annoying
white even has threats like this coming
on 94 coming and that it's just
extremely inconvenient it's also
difficult to prepare queenside castling
you can argue that you can play a six to
stop Bishop b5 and then cancel Queen
side but then the sacrifice on a6
becomes really yeah awful possibility
and long story short this is one of
those cases where I recommend to go King
side in comparison to other setups this
is not as dangerous for black as it is
compared to white having the Queen on d2
for example and the bishop still on f1
one thing is that you don't necessarily
need the bishop on d3 and the Queen on
d2 is supporting most like 95 a little
better than the Queen only Tudors
so this is a little bit of them yeah
some optimal setup for white for
opposite sides castling one difference I
want to point out though if white now
centralizes the rook and itself if you
enjoyed the free video preview make sure
to go to chesterlaw.com slash fight like
a karana to get to the full course the
full course with the move trainer and
video sync technology is an excellent
way to learn all the ideas and
strategies connected to this repertoire
these lines were essential in kiwanis
fight to get the world title match and
they can be an essential part of your
opening repertoire as well
[Music]